[Applaus]
[Musik]
the time has come for new programm ob
national building
can call inka grings die producerin race
at least one point feiert twin towers
von new and the structure investment
des bradley nils
[Musik]
nicht nur ein zwei oder drei sondern
schon ganz viele präsidenten haben
versucht die aufmerksamkeit auf das
massive infrastruktur probleme ihres
landes zu lenken ein problem das die
wettbewerbsfähigkeit die zukunft und vor
allem die sicherheit der vereinigten
staaten schwer belastet während nämlich
in asien und europa riesige summen in
einem modernen infrastruktur sowie die
instandhaltung bestehender anlagen
investiert werden sind in den usa viele
davon vor allem im bereich des
transportwesens in einem unvorstellbar
maroden zustand das licht schafft ist
das land mit der größten volkswirtschaft
der welt nicht einmal in die top ten
wenn es um die qualität der
infrastruktur geht diese top ten
surprise surprise wird vollständig durch
asiatische und europäische länder
besetzt aber auch ihren 30 platz
erreichen die usa nur dann enorme menge
an infrastruktur die ein entwickeltes
land mit so großen entfernungen nun mal
benötigt als mit ihrem aktuellen zustand
oder ihrer zukunftsfähigkeit masse statt
klasse
so manchen mag es zwar überraschen aber
für die autofahrer der führenden
weltmacht dieses planeten ist es
durchaus üblich täglich über schlagloch
pisten brettern zu müssen und auch
eisenbahnen unfälle sind keine
seltenheit einstürze von brücken
aufgrund mangelnder wartung kommen auch
weiteres häufiger vor als man es in
einem land mit so großem
wirtschaftlichen ressourcen erwarten
würde in diesem video analysieren wir
daher die schlüsselfaktoren die den
großen infrastruktur problem der usa zu
grunde liegen und wie der aktuelle
mieter im weißen haus ein älterer herr
namens joe biden es zu lösen gedenkt sie
bietet keine voreiligen schlüsse joe
biden mag es nicht gerade wie ein
revolutionär wirken aber seine
infrastruktur planen wird dich
überraschen wenn dieser plan sieht weder
so aus wie du in dir wahrscheinlich
vorgestellt hast noch ist es der plan
die sich die amerikaner wohl gewünscht
hätten was ich damit meine aktuell sehen
sich die usa mit einem schweren
ungleichgewicht in ihrem staatshaushalt
konfrontiert dass bereits zu maßnahmen
wie der größte steuererhöhung seit 1993
geführt hat am ende dieses videos was du
daher genau verstehen warum dieses thema
eine so große rolle für die zukunft
amerikas als wirtschaftsmacht und daher
für die gesamte weltwirtschaft spielt
also bist du bereit sich mit uns auf
dieser reise ins land der unendlich
maroh infrastruktur zu machen gut zu
lasst uns sofort loslegen
[Musik]
eine multi millionen dollar
das ist um die infrastruktur der usa
steht haben wir ja bereits erwähnt aber
was konkret bedeutet das die schlecht
ist es wirklich um sie bestellt also
wenn du zum beispiel auf den straßen
wisconsins unterwegs bist solltest du
besser anfangen geld für neue reifen und
stoßdämpfer beiseite zu legen denn rot
82 prozent aller straßen dort befinden
sich in einem maroden zustand und falls
du in die usa auswandern möchtest du
dich doch mit einer kfz werkstatt
selbstständig zu machen dann weißt du
durch unseren heißen tipp bereits in
welchem staat du dich am besten
niederlassen sollte ist ja da sagt man
einer visual politik würde seinen
zuschauern keine praktischen karriere
tipps vermitteln aber weiter in unserem
reiseführer wenn du eines tages so mutig
sein solltest im bundesstaat new jersey
mit dem zug zu fahren raten wir dringend
vorher eine anständige
auslandskrankenversicherung
abzuschließen am besten im paket mit
invalidenrente und
risikolebensversicherung denn allein
zwischen 2015 und 2019 und leisten in
nur diesem einen bundesstaat nicht
weniger als 100 die züge dass eine ganze
elf vorfälle pro 100 meilen strecke und
wenn du gar so heiß breche strauch sein
sollte es über eine brücke in roth eilen
zu fahren solltest du immer einen
glücksbringer dabei haben denn zwei von
zehn drücken in diesem staat haben
schwere bauliche mängel
dies ist natürlich noch eine kleine
aufzählung drei anekdotische beispiele
von unzähligen vielen denn fakt ist dass
auf nationaler ebene und 22 prozent der
straßen und 7,6 prozent der brücken
marode sind und diese zahlen sind alles
andere als typisch für ein entwickeltes
land geschweige denn für die führende
wirtschaftsmacht der welt dieses problem
stellt nicht nur eine akute gefahr für
leib und leben der reisenden da sondern
verursacht auch gigantische
volkswirtschaftliche schäden da ist die
wettbewerbsfähigkeit der unternehmen
unter kriegt bröckelt der infrastruktur
schadet amerikas wettbewerbsfähigkeit
und nicht nur das es wird geschätzt dass
allein für die reparatur und
modernisierung von straßen und
rückenwindes 786 milliarden dollar
benötigt werden und das betrifft nur die
instandhaltung der bereits bestehenden
infrastruktur keine dringend notwendigen
kapazitätserweiterungen des aus allen
nähten berstenden und chronisch
überlasteten verkehrssystems genau es
geht einfach nur darum die bestehende
infrastruktur wieder einigermaßen sicher
und nutzbar zu machen sie in einen
zustand zu bringen indem sie wieder das
leisten kann wofür sie mal ursprünglich
konzipiert wurde und fast immer noch
denkt dass nicht übertreibe wenn ich dir
sagte dass die kohle für neue reifen und
dämpfer bereit halten soll es dann
passiert mal gut auf
nach schätzungen der american society of
engineers geben autofahrer den usa jedes
jahr 130 milliarden dollar für
reparaturen an ihren fahrzeugen aufgrund
des miesen zustand der fahrbahnen aus
das ist immerhin ein sechstel je nach
summe die man bräuchte um straßen und
brücken auf den neuesten stand zu
bringen wenn man also alles auf einmal
repariert würde wäre das geld nur sechs
jahren wieder drin durch vermiedene
fahrzeugschäden
egal wie man es also betrachtet die
extreme sparsamkeit bei der straßen
instandhaltung ist nichts anderes als
eine gefährliche und fahrlässige
kostenverlagerung vom staat hin zu den
verkehrsteilnehmern der zustand der
straßen ist jedoch nur die spitze des
eisbergs ein anderer gewaltiger
schandfleck der usa befindet sich
nämlich an einer ganz entgegengesetzten
stelle an einer stelle wo ihn die
meisten von raul ich wahrscheinlich gar
nicht erwarten würden in der luft okay
also nicht direkt oben am himmel aber
eben bei der luftfahrt die meisten us
flughäfen sind nämlich vollkommen in den
1970 er und 80 er jahren stecken
geblieben sie gehörten einst zu den
besten aber der mangel an upgrades
modernisierungen und erweiterungen hat
die vereinigten staaten zu einem der
reichsten länder mit den am stärksten
veralteten in überlasteten flughäfen der
welt gemacht in der tat schafft es kein
einziger us flughafen in die top 25 der
besten flughäfen der welt und das ist
beileibe kein wunder viele große us
flughäfen wie zum beispiel der new
yorker airport sind einfach vollkommen
unterdimensioniert zumindest waren sie
das vor corona das führt natürlich zu
verspätungen was wiederum zu
wirtschaftlichen verlusten in
millionenhöhe für die fluggesellschaften
und einer geringeren servicequalität für
die passagiere führt aber die frage die
sich viele von euch sich erstellen ist
warum um alles in der welt ist das denn
so warum ist die infrastruktur in den
vereinigten staaten so mangelhaft wie
konnte es soweit kommen wieso haben die
amis alles so verkommen lassen nun genau
das werden wir es herausfinden
houston wir haben ein problem
[Musik]
um zu verstehen warum die
verkehrsinfrastruktur in den usa so
schlecht ist müssen wir ein bisschen
über politik ein bisschen über
geschichte und natürlich auch ein
bisschen über geld reden wollte da wir
hier bei visual politik sind dann wir
natürlich mit der politik an in den
vereinigten staaten gibt es wie alle bis
zwei große parteien die demokratische
partei und die republikanische partei
nun weiter parteien treten
verständlicherweise eigentlich für die
verbesserung der verkehrsinfrastruktur
ein paar freudig nicht zu früh zu ende
sie sind sich meist nicht einig wie
genau das geschehen soll das größte
problem liegt auf der bundesebene also
bei den investitionen der
bundesregierung die vorher vom kongress
genehmigt werden müssen
denn natürlich sind die republikaner der
meinung dass das geld aus einem
infrastrukturplan in erster linie in die
verbesserung und den bau von straßen und
autobahnen fließen sollte damit die
menschen mit ihrem eigenen auto
problemlos von a nach b gelangen können
die demokraten hingegen sind der meinung
dass die gelder in den ausbau eines
guten bahn und öffentlichen
verkehrsnetzes fließen sollten es
handelt sich um nichts geringeres als
ein weiteres schlachtfeld im unendlichen
krieg zwischen individualismus und
kollektivismus der in diesem fall jedoch
ins lächerliche ausartet straßen zu
verbessern damit jeder leicht überall
dorthin gelangen kann wo er hinwill ist
für die einen freiheit und für die
anderen etwas unerträglich ist ein
absoluter rückschritt in die längst
überwunden geglaubt dass vergangenheit
für die einen ist die förderung der
eisenbahn und öffentlicher
verkehrsmittel fast eine ausgeburt des
sozialismus da dies ja bedeuten würde
die bewegungsmöglichkeiten der menschen
zu kontrollieren und start nicht zu
lenken für die anderen stellt sich auf
eine messianische konzept die zukunft
der nachhaltigen mobilität den weg ins
paradies dar tatsache ist dass diese
andauernde debatte zeugt vor allem davon
dass es am ende niemals einen konsens
für einen umfassenden plan geben wird
damit genügend mitteln ausgestattet wäre
um die infrastruktur des landes durch
reparieren und zu erneuern und das ist
der grund warum wir am anfang sagte dass
alle präsidenten es immer wieder
versuchten aber am ende kein einziger
erfolgreich war denn los wir beachten
müssen ist die tatsache dass der größte
teil der us verkehrsinfrastruktur in
einem relativ kurzen zeitraum zwischen
den 950 jahre und nutzen den 70er jahren
gebaut wurde wenn es um alte rom geht
befindet sich also das ganze
verkehrsnetz mehr oder weniger auf dem
gleichen niveau des verfalls das macht
es natürlich besonders schwer die für
die reparaturmaßnahmen notwendigen
ressourcen kontinuierlich und
abwechselnd einzusetzen sowie diesen
anderen ländern üblich ist in denen
jedes jahr nur bestimmte begrenzte teile
der infrastruktur repariert werden
müssen die usa bräuchten also quasi
einen riesigen baut druck für das ganze
land auf einmal aber das ist nur der
anfang der probleme denn an dieser
stelle müssen wir uns gibt es sagt
drehend über geld unterhalten die mittel
für instandhaltung und bau von u- s- und
u-bahnen können aus zwei quellen stammen
von den bundesstaaten und kommunalen
trägern auf der einen seite und von der
bundesregierung auf der anderen letztere
finanziert ihren beitrag über den
sogenannten host fand
[Musik]
das ist ein song der durch die
mineralölsteuer des bundes gespeist wird
diese beträgt seit 1993 unverändert 18,4
cent pro gallone benzin und 24 cent pro
gallone diesel dieses modell hat jedoch
drei große probleme das erste ist dass
die mineralölsteuer nicht als
prozentsatz bemessen ist sondern als ex
betrag der eben seit notruf 93 nicht
mehr angepasst wurde sodass das regale
steueraufkommen inflationsbedingt
aufhören die hälfte gesunken ist das
zweite problem ist dass mit dem
vormarsch effizienterer fahrzeuge und
dem aufkommen von elektroautos der
verbrauch an fossilen stoffen mal im
verhältnis zur anzahl der auf den
strassen verkehren fahrzeuge deutlich
gesunken ist und damit auch die erträge
dieser steuer das ergebnis ist dass der
hype etwas dran seit einiger zeit aus
anderen steuertöpfen bezuschusst werden
muss wenn auch in unzureichendem maße
und natürlich entgegen des prinzips auf
dem dieser vor 956 geschaffen wurde denn
dieses prinzip bestand im grunde darin
das nest durch eine umlage ähnliches
system zu finanzieren
tja und stattdessen erhielt der fonds
zwischen 2008 und 2010 34 5 milliarden
us-dollar an überweisungen aus dem
finanzministerium und in der praxis
bedeutet die schlechte wirtschaftliche
nachhaltigkeit des fonds dass immer
weniger bundesgelder für die
instandhaltung in den bau von straßen
und brücken bereitgestellt werden und
die starten bei dieser aufgabe zunehmend
auf sich allein gestellt sind doch woher
stammen die mittel der bundesstaaten zur
straßen und autobahnen und wie hoch
fallen diese überhaupt aus
nun die staaten und kommunen haben ihr
eigenes system um die auch irgendwie
beat verlaufe straßen und autobahnen zu
finanzieren zum einen gibt es weitere
bundesstaat nicht oder gar kommunale
kraftstoff steuern also einen aufschlag
auf die bundessteuer und zum anderen
mautgebühren wenn die bundesregierung
nun immer weniger geld beisteuert haben
die bundesstaaten und kommunen nur zwei
möglichkeiten sie erhöhen ihre eigenen
steuern und gebühren oder sie lassen die
straßen verrotten und nun ist es so dass
einige staaten die erste option wählen
und andere nichts weiter wenn wir aber
über konkrete zahlen sprechen muss man
feststellen dass die vereinigten staaten
insgesamt etwa 135 milliarden dollar pro
jahr für straßen ausgeben wo von etwa 50
milliarden dollar auch die bundesstaaten
über kraft versteuern und etwa 20
milliarden dollar braucht gebühren
entfallen so dass die bundesregierung
nur ein drittel das geld ist etwa 50
milliarden beisteuern
ein weiteres dilemma an dieser ganzen
geschichte ist dass niemand die der bund
durch die bundesstaaten den mut haben
die höhe der mineralölsteuer anzutasten
gleichzeitig will aber auch niemand von
ihnen die mehrausgaben für die
straßenreparatur schultern in dem andere
finanztöpfe angezapft werden denn dann
müssten ja andere ressorts bluten und
die stellt sich dann immer quer und so
war das schwarze peter der infrastruktur
jahr für jahr monat für monat weiter und
die straßen und brücken in den
vereinigten staaten verfallen
währenddessen immer näher ebenso
natürlich auch das schienennetz und die
flughäfen gibt es für dieses problem
also eine lösung nun erscheint das der
einzige ausweg aus dieser misere oder
mcdonald transporten der wiederaufbau
der nation nur durch die bundesregierung
beschritten werden kann ist ein massiver
infrastruktur investitionsplan des
bundes deutlich schlechter oder nun das
ist genau das was joe biden zu tun
gedenkt die eisbahn ist aber ob es
diesmal funktionieren wird oder
scheitern wie jedes mal zuvor und genau
das werden wir uns anschauen
[Musik]
es gibt einen plan schon wieder
bereits kurz nach seinem amtsantritt im
märz 2021 der beiden seine tollkühnes
vorhaben bekannt beiden kündigt riesigen
infrastrukturplan an um die zukunft zu
gewinnen präsident joe biden diskutiert
mittwoch einen riesigen 2,3 billionen
dollar plan um die infrastruktur der
nation zu erneuern was er als eine
einmalige investition in amerika
bezeichnete so und was ist also aus
beiden plan geworden wohl mittlerweile
haben sich beide kann man der
amerikanischen gesetzgebung also der
us-senat und auch der kongress geeinigt
und immer haben sie den plan des
präsidenten ziemlich zerrupft mache
jetzt aber nicht den fehler zu glauben
dies liege nur daran dass die
republikaner im senat exakt 50 prozent
der sitze halten seien auch verschiedene
gruppierungen der demokraten im kongress
haben das vorhaben lange blockiert und
ihre partikularinteressen durchzusetzen
also was ist denn nun dabei
herausgekommen nun auf den ersten blick
eigentlich ein ganz ordentliches paket
der hatte dich fest demokraten und
republikaner haben sich nicht lumpen
lassen und bliesen beiden programm auf
sage und schreibe 45 billionen dollar
auf ja wir sprechen von 45 millionen
millionen dollar diese soll zwar über
zehn jahre verteilt ausgegeben werden
aber trotzdem es ist einer der
ambitioniertesten ausgabenpläne in der
geschichte des landes aber warte einen
moment bevor du sagst gut dann ist das
erklärt die werden jetzt endlich geld in
straßen brücken flughäfen und eisenbahn
investieren also ist alles gelöst nein
so einfach ist das nicht denn es gibt da
noch das kleingedruckte
[Musik]
das erste was man berücksichtigen müssen
ist dass von diesen 45 millionen dollar
nur 550 milliarden dollar für die
verkehrsinfrastruktur bestimmt sind also
etwa 55 milliarden dollar pro jahr und
von diesen 550 milliarden dollar sollen
erst einmal nur vergleichsweise mickrige
100 milliarden in die reparatur von
straßen und brücken fließen also nur elf
milliarden dollar pro jahr mit anderen
worten nur ein fünftel dessen was die
bundesregierung bereits durch den
highways ostwand bereitstellt unterm
strich haben wir es also wieder einmal
wie bei jedem präsidenten mit einer
luftnummer zu tun denn erinnerst du
nicht noch was wir am anfang des videos
gesagt haben dass 786 milliarden dollar
allein für die reparatur von straßen und
brücken benötigt werden der nun
verabschiedete plan würde nicht einmal
ein sechstel dessen abdeckung was nach
expertenmeinung nötig ist
[Musik]
und das ist noch nicht alles die total
veralteten flughäfen die bereits erwähnt
haben würden über einen zeitraum von
zehn jahren die täglich 25 milliarden
dollar erhalten und damit werden noch
nicht einmal alle notwendigen
sicherheitsrelevante verbesserungen
durchzuführen sein vor allem wenn man
bedenkt die die inflation in den
nächsten zehn jahren den wert dieser
summe zusammen schmelzen lässt und was
ist mit den öffentlichen verkehrsnetz
nun das soll 105 milliarden dollar
erhalten 66 milliarden davon soll ins
fernzug nissan trek fließen
auch das eigentlich nur ein tropfen auf
den heißen stein aber an dieser stelle
bin ich mir sicher dass du dich schon
die ganze zeit fragt wo zum teufel denn
der rest des geldes geblieben ist nun
irgendwie wird oder den hochtrabenden
begriff infrastruktur so ziemlich alles
bedient was nicht bei drei auf den
bäumen ist schließlich wollte ja jede
interessengruppe jede lobby jeder
wahlkreis und jeder abgeordnete etwas
von diesen 4,5 millionen kuchen abhaben
726 milliarden dollar sind zum beispiel
klassische sozialausgaben von der
kinderbetreuung bis zur pandemievorsorge
332 milliarden kommen der
wohnraumförderung zugute 73 milliarden
fließen ins stromnetz mit 65 milliarden
wörter ausbau der highspeed internet
verbindungen vorangetrieben und 55
milliarden sollten für die versorgung
mit sauberem trinkwasser ausgegeben
werden natürlich all diese ausgaben
klingen vernünftig und sind wohl auch
bitter nötig
[Musik]
am weiteren verfall der
verkehrsinfrastruktur und den damit
verbundenen enormen
volkswirtschaftlichen schäden wird sich
jedoch nichts ändern und das ist
besonders fatal engen zusammenhang nicht
eine andere frage wo nämlich will der
staat diese riesige menge an geld
hernehmen nun zunächst einmal werden
dies ausgaben für ein noch höheres
haushaltsdefizit sorgen welches dann
über neuverschuldung und die
gelddruckmaschine der fed kompensiert
werden muss beiden hat jedoch auch noch
folgenden plan
will den infrastrukturplan über 15 jahre
mit höheren unternehmens steuern
bezahlen es geht also um die erhöhung
der bundes körperschaftsteuer von 21
prozent auf 28 was wenn wir noch die
unternehmen spüren die einzelnen
bundesstaaten berücksichtigen die usa
wieder einmal als das gcb und g7 land
mit den höchsten kombinierten satz
dieser steuern platzieren würde bei über
32 prozent in der praxis würde dies
heißen dass der größte teil der kosten
von den unternehmen getragen wird das
problem dabei es ist quasi einen
doppelschlag gegen die
wettbewerbsfähigkeit der amerikanischen
wirtschaft sie wird in noch höherem maße
unter der vernachlässigung der
infrastruktur leiden und dafür auch noch
verstärkt zur kasse gebeten das ist so
als wenn es in einer wohnung immer
stärker von der decke tropft weil ein
vermieter zu geizig ist das dach zu
flicken und jetzt also noch kräftig die
miete erhöht beiden infrastrukturplan
wird aber noch aufgrund anderer probleme
kritisiert
so wird er von einigen analysten als
eine rezente realisierung der
infrastrukturpolitik betrachtet da er
vorsieht dass hauptsächlich die
bundesregierung entscheidet wofür das
geld ausgegeben wird etwas was in den
vereinigten staaten mit ihren hohen grad
an föderalismus und dezentralisierung
überhaupt nicht üblich ist aber
natürlich erfordert große ausgaben große
ausreden und in diesem fall ist beides
ausrede die angebliche schaffung von 19
millionen arbeitslosen bis 2030 klar die
investitionen werden einen weiteren bau
boom auslösen aber erstmal dieser zu
ende geht wird sich zeigen wie viele
arbeitsplätze eigentlich dauerhaft
bestehen bleiben und dann muss man auch
diejenigen jobs abziehen welche durch
die steuererhöhungen vernichtet worden
und auf basis dieser differenz kann eine
bilanz gezogen werden wie viel jeder
reisende zusätzlich weiß klaas den
steuerzahler unterm strich gekostet hat
an diesem punkt müssen wir uns jedoch
die frage stellen ob es nicht
alternativen gibt mit welchen man das
infrastruktur problem der usa lösen
könnte ohne steuererhöhungen und
zentralismus nun lasst uns dafür mal
einen blick nach down under werfen wie
geht australien das infrastruktur
probleme ab
[Musik]
australien auch bekannt als die
vereinigten staaten 2.0 implementiert
ein innovatives anderes system um seine
infrastruktur zu finanzieren
dieses modell besteht im kern darin dass
die regierung in schlechtem zustand
befindliche infrastruktur privaten
betreibern zum kauf anbietet und das
daraus erlösten geld dann verwendet um
in neue infrastruktur zu investieren das
ganze hat einen doppelten vorteil durch
die neue infrastruktur werden
kapazitätsengpässe geschlossen und die
alte infrastruktur wird durch den
privaten betreiber saniert dieser erhält
daraufhin das recht sich zu betreiben
und dadurch sein investment mit der zeit
zu refinanzieren auf diese weise ist es
möglich ein neues stück infrastruktur zu
finanzieren und gleichzeitig die
bestehende zu sanieren ohne auf
steuererhöhungen und neue verschuldung
zurückgreifen zu müssen und um noch
weiter zu gehen sieht das modell auch
vor dass neue infrastruktur linie diesem
geld gebaut wird über das gleiche system
auch privatisiert werden kann die idee
dahinter ist also dass sich das modell
ständig selbst regeneriert sah was
meinst du dazu klingt das australische
modell wie eine nachhaltigere und
wirtschaftlich effiziente option als joe
biden ausgabe welche den tatsächlichen
bedarf jedoch nicht annähernd
befriedigen kann oder hat auch die
australische lösung ihre haken glaubst
du das ist nur das problem der über
jahrzehnte vernachlässigten
infrastruktur der usa überhaupt eine
lösung gibt teilt eure meinung bitte die
immer mit uns und auch allen anderen ich
hoffe dass euch dieses video gefallen
hat was ja gibt es mit einem leicht
alten freunden und vergesst nicht
unseren kanal zu abonnieren was gut und
bis bald
[Musik]